it's a rather simple question that
quickly gets to the core of someone's
sense of well-being and legitimacy did
your childhood leave you feeling that
you were on balance okay as you were
or did you somewhere along the way
derive an impression that you needed to
be extraordinary in order to deserve a
place on the earth and to raise an
associated question are you therefore
now relaxed about your status or else
either a manic overachiever or filled
with shame at your so-called mediocrity
around 20% of us will be in the
uncomfortable cohort alternately
refusing to believe that anything could
ever be enough or cursing ourselves as
failures by which we in essence mean
that we have not managed to beat insane
statistical odds at school we probably
worked very hard not because we were
drawn to the topics but because we felt
compelled for reasons that were at the
time not entirely clear we just knew we
had to come close to the top of the
class and revise every evening we may
not be exceptional right now but we are
seldom without an acute sense of
pressure to be so in childhood the story
might have gone like this a parent
needed us to be special
by virtue of intelligence looks or
popularity in order to shore up a
floundering sense of their own self the
child needed to achieve and could not
therefore just be their own motives and
tastes were not part of the picture the
parent was privately in pain unable to
value themselves battling an unnamed
depression furious with the course of
their own lives
perhaps covertly tortured by a spouse
and the child's mission for which there
was no option but to volunteer was to
make it all somehow better it seems odd
to look at achievement through this lens
not as the thing that the newspapers
tell us it is but very often as a
species of mental illness those who put
up the skyscrapers write the
best-selling books perform on stage or
make partner may in fact be
the unwell ones whereas the characters
who without agony can bear an ordinary
life the so-called contented
mediocrities may in fact be the
emotional superstars the aristocrats of
the spirit the captains of the heart the
world divides into the privileged who
can be ordinary and the Damned compelled
to be remarkable the best possible
outcome for the latter is to have a
breakdown suddenly after years of
achievement they can if they're lucky no
longer get out of bed they fall into a
profound depression they develop
all-consuming social anxiety they refuse
to eat they babble incoherently they in
some way poke a very large stick in the
wheels of day-to-day life and are
allowed to stay home for a while a
breakdown is not merely a random piece
of madness or malfunction it can be a
very real albeit inarticulate and
inconvenient bid for health it is an
attempt by one part of our minds to
force the other into a process of growth
self understanding and self-development
which it has hitherto been too coward to
undertake if we can put it paradoxically
it is an attempt to jumpstart a process
of getting well properly well through a
stage of falling very ill in an
apparently ill State we might cleverly
be seeking to destroy all the building
blocks of our previous driven yet
unhappy careers we may be trying to
reduce our commitments and our outgoings
we may be trying to throw off the cruel
absurdity of other people's expectations
our societies that are often unwell at a
collective and not just at an individual
level are predictably lacking in
inspiring images of good enough ordinary
lives they tend to associate these with
being a loser we imagine that a quiet
life is something that only a failed
person without options would ever seek
we relentlessly identify goodness with
being at the centre in the metropolis on
the stage we don't like autumn
mellowness or the peace that comes once
we are past
Meridian of our hopes but there is of
course no center or rather the center is
oneself occasionally an artist will make
things that bring such a pathetic wisdom
home here is martini capturing the point
in the third volume of his essays
written a few years before his death
towards the end of the 16th century
storming a breach conducting an embassy
ruling a nation are glittering deeds
rebuking laughing buying selling loving
hating and living together
gently and justly with your household
and with yourself not getting slack
noble lying yourself is something more
remarkable more rare and more difficult
whatever people may say such secluded
lives sustained in that way duties which
are at least as hard and as tense as
those of other lives in the late 1650s
the Dutch artist Johannes Vermeer
painted a picture called the little
Street that continues to challenge our
value system to this day perhaps success
might after all be nothing more than a
quiet afternoon with the children at
home in a modest Street you catch a
similar point in certain stories by
Chekhov for Raymond Carver in Bob
Dylan's time out of mind in Thomas
Jones's study of a wall in Naples and in
the films of Erik Hamer in particular
Lucca affair most movies adverts songs
and articles however do not tend to go
this way they continually explained to
us the appeal of other things sports
cars tropical island holidays Fame an
exalted destiny first-class air travel
and being very very busy the attractions
are sometimes perfectly real but the
cumulative effect is to instill in us
the idea that our own lives must be
close to worthless and yet there may be
immense skill joy and nobility involved
in what we're up to in bringing up a
child to be reasonably independent and
balanced in maintaining a good enough
relationship with a partner over many
years despite areas of extreme
difficulty in keeping a home in
reasonable order in getting a lot of
early nights in doing a not very
exciting or well
job responsibly and cheerfully in
listening properly to other people and
in general in not succumbing to madness
or rage at the paradox and compromises
involved in being alive there is already
a Treasury to appreciate in our
circumstances when we learn to see these
without prejudice or self-hatred as we
may discover once we are beyond others
expectations life's true luxuries might
comprise nothing more or less a
simplicity quiet friendship are based on
vulnerability creativity without an
audience love without too much hope or
despair hot baths and dried fruits
walnuts and a little bit of dark
chocolate the school of life is coming
to New York from the 4th to the 6th of
October for a three-day conference where
you'll have the chance to meet other
like-minded individuals and embark on a
journey of genuine self-discovery and
self transformation we hope to see you
there